[Music]
residents inside the spanish trails
country club are outraged over animal
cruelty they say the geese that roam the
neighborhood are now being killed and
now residents are organizing to stop it
literally they have massacred brutally
almost the entire population of canadian
geese dana souter has been a spanish
trail country club resident for eight
years but says life now inside this
community is far from paradise astrocity
that's happening in my own backyard
is absolutely outrageous
torturing and killing animals is
shameful
neighbors shared videos that were too
graphic to show of how the animals were
treated some say it's animal cruelty
suiter says it's legal to prevent
property damage residents say it's hard
to watch this time last year you would
see
you would see
canadian geese everywhere with their
geeseling and literally today here we
stand there's i see maybe five maybe six
throughout the entire community eight
news now was invited into the
neighborhood by suiter to see the lack
of geese but management for spanish
trails prevented us from recording
adding they had no comment over this
matter in a statement the nevada
department of wildlife says the spanish
trails country club did indeed have a
permit to remove geese and are currently
investigating whether or not the
requirements of the permit were followed
for now the permit has been suspended
[Music]